my biggest thing I say on like
interviews in Recruitment and and
outside of recruitment right is focusing
on me I focus on me I want it to be a
better person I want it to be happy I
want it to be more fulfilled I wanted to
create in my mindset that I'm enjoying
what I'm doing like just work sleep work
sleep is not enough for me welcome back
to the show this week I was joined by
Jamie Fraser the CEO of the interx group
we l sat down 3 years ago
yeah back then he was a team of 15
people turning over million since then
he's been busy and over the last 3 years
the interest group has opened offices in
Miami New York the Netherlands and
they've grown to 100 plus people and
last year they turned over £65 million
ever since getting to know Jam three
plus years ago the belief the passion he
had for building a platform that breeds
high performance Excellence was evident
however ever he's had to do a lot of
self-work like we all have to do
personal development become the person
that you need to become and he's really
developed and grown which he speaks a
lot about in this conversation to become
the CEO and the business leader he is
today and he knows he needs to be for
the future of the company tell us a bit
about this training that you're really
passionate about yeah put training to
one side just for one minute it first
starts with enjoy this week's episode
Jamie welcome to the thanks for having
me we sat down as I was just saying we
sat down 3 years ago yeah uh office in
Bank 15 people I came to your office
good office that yeah lots of
memories um yeah and I think you know
where you are now as a business it's
it's been some Journey right so would
you mind just just quickly I've got some
key points here but I'll just add some
of the bits but you might have to help
me out so when we last sat down yeah
there's around 15 people office in Bank
um I wrote down here he was turning over
around 9 million um and now you're Circ
100 plus people You' be to hand me out
exactly but you've got a global presence
it's you had an office in UK but you was
doing a lot in Europe in terms of
business but yeah office in UK office in
Miami you've opened up New York and then
I'm not sure if you have one in
Amsterdam or you've got one in Mainland
Europe but help me out here what are the
other core bits of like what the
business looks like today in terms of
how many people where your best yeah
yeah for sure so 120 heads um we we
wanted to grow with more last year but
market conditions and stuff like that
like we done well but from a performance
perspective versus like budget um it
wasn't where we wanted to be from a gold
perspective but we grew and we done
everything organic um so everything we
done like last year and like since we
last met was about doing exactly what we
said we're going to do M and I think
that's my biggest thing right is instead
of me talking about it I wanted to show
that it's not we try everyone I said to
in my uh interviews and I speak to is
that we're going to do this and I'm big
about that from a mindset perspective
it's that if we say we're going to do
something we're going to make it happen
and we did we we've made stuff happen
everything we've done is been an organic
growth you know we we we launched Miami
a year and a half ago in the space of 12
months we've got our contract book
running into 200k a week dollars right
and that's super quick the first time I
ever stepped in the States was when I
open up that office I actually went on a
stago and I thought [__] I don't know if
this is the right the right move right
but um no I stuck stuck at it and I I
love the place now it's like my my home
and then we open up New York so
everything we've done has been organic
growth but everything I've done has been
at reinvestment like we worked out the
amount of investment from a fund
perspective last year we did was just
ginormous it was huge because my
strategy was that I don't want various
people doing multiple hats okay I'm
playing multiple hats sorry because I
wanted everyone to be an expert in an
where it be compliance Finance HR people
whatever that looks like I wanted to
bring the best in I wanted to cherry
pick the best in the market bring them
in to elevate us to be to where we are
today and we're in the best position
possible that I could possibly be and
I'm so grateful for the position we're
in now for the next day so so help me
understand cuz I was just saying to you
when we last sat down with where you
were as a business you literally
described yourself as like a business
development Direct that's definitely not
going to be the case now so as the CEO
of of this business today like if I was
to look at Jam's like time maybe in like
a pie chart what are like the core
activities that now Jamie the CEO does
that might be quite interesting just to
understand that I'm super Hands-On right
so just because I've delegated we've
created different structures and
processes with people it doesn't mean
that I don't want to be involved I'm
obsessed with being involved in this
business I love the ideas I love driving
ideas and change I run training I give
you an example right right right now is
I'm running I have another business
around growth and mindset and stuff like
that and I'm doing four sessions all
about mindset with each office so I'm
flying out to each office over the next
three weeks and I'm going to be
delivering that training I'm involved in
BD still I love winning big clients our
biggest client wins I've been involved
in you know and I love being involved in
it I love my Miami team especially and
also New York to to use me as the BD
lead to help win that I'm big on
strategy I'm big on Direction I'm
involved in a lot of things and like my
chairman was always about you need to be
on top of the business and I do want to
be on top of the business but I run
Miami last year you know and I've helped
set up New York not on the
infrastructure from a driving and
strategy perspective right and I I I
would say I'm still involved in
absolutely everything you know I'm still
in early I'm still leave late I I still
I still drive the business I'm still
handson you know I have all sales of
leaders reporting into me globally MH
not every sales leader but like office
leads and directors all appoints me
globally um I've got some sales people
reporting to me directly these are the
people that I've Cherry Picked that I
think are absolutely phenomenal at a job
and I want to work with so I I'm still
involved in a lot you know I work very
closely with my coo MH we bounc a lot of
ideas off each other and we we we both
jump into each other's roles um and work
with each other quite closely it's quite
it's quite unique to be honest with you
and I I always thought that bringing
someone like Amy into the business how
is that going to work right she's going
to take over a massive piece of my pie
because she controls everything
operations but it worked like so well so
I want us to talk
about how we got to this point and then
what like how you're approaching going
ahead cuz I know you said in a few
different places when I prepared for
this like over the next 3 three and a
half years you want to get to an exit
and some sort of business event so I
think what people would be really
interested in is like how we got to this
point cuz when we last sat down 15
people now 120 people different offices
coo I remember you telling me that like
you sometimes thought I wish I could
have started this as someone like
starting out is really difficult right
you've now got Amy's been with you for
six or so months and already having a
big impact so like yeah there's been a
lot of growth here and I think a lot of
people say they want to get to where you
get to but they maybe not get there
right so I think that's why I think just
starting with how we got to this point I
think why don't I just ask you firstly
what have what have been some of the
biggest shifts you've had to make as a
CEO like when we last sat down you
described yourself different probably
how you're going to describe yourself
now so whether it be mentally or how you
approach your work or where you see your
purpose in inter in your own business
what have been some of the biggest
shifts you've had to make from being a
15 person company to 120 person company
my biggest thing I say on like
interviews in Recruitment and and
outside of recruitment right is focusing
on me I focus on me I want it to be a
better person I want it to be happy I
want it to be more fulfilled
I I I wanted to create in my mindset
that um I'm enjoying what I'm doing like
just work sleep work sleep is not enough
for me I believe that I'm here for a
bigger reason than just that um and I
say a lot is how can I make impact on
people so so changing my view of just
being like a sales leader like who's
just about driving sales and you know
bringing sales in which we've done very
well with and I created some absolute
machines within my business but um I
want to make impact on people's lives
now and that's to difference um I want
to be clearer in my head I want to be a
lot more calm and collective in terms of
how I approach things um I want people
to buy into me right I want I want to be
the CEO in the industry that people buy
into I'm young I've achieved a heck of a
lot I've I'm proven in my industry from
a Sal's perspective I believe I'm an
all-rounded CEO right which allowed me
to win my Awards last year that got me
to everything I needed to get to because
of my change of who I wanted to be and I
created that vision and self-discovered
and I understood more about me that's
allowed me to I want to be different I
want to stand out and like my goal for
this year is I want to stand out from
every
CEO what I really noticed which I
absolutely love is just this absolute
commitment of you investing in yourself
like I think it was on one of your posts
recently and you might have mentioned it
before but I think you put on there like
always work with coaches so you put you
have a coach for your business
public speaking breath work therapist
personal trainer
nutritionist like that I I I really
respect that CU it can be very easy for
you as you you know there's a lot of
evidence to go if I just keep doing this
we're going to keep making more money
but you continue to get out of your
comfort zone and invest in areas that
you probably was aware that you needed
to become more all-rounded and an
overall better person so like why why
the overall commitment to that and why
invest in these things cuz a lot of W
yeah of I again I want to stand out I
want to prove people wrong like before I
for everyone watching right I wasn't a
natural sales person I had a stutter I
had a lot of hardships not backs and
failes in my life um I low self-esteem
and I created the person I am today and
in recruitment everyone talks about Sals
and learning Sals that's not how you get
to Elite levels to get to Elite levels
you need to self master self-discover
and need to learn about your mindset and
we'll come on to it later right in terms
of how we Elevate that in intera but I'm
obsessed with being the best version of
me I'm obsessed of more I'm obsessed of
doing more like I said in one of my
podcasts the other day I'm not wasting
no time this year okay and it doesn't
mean I'm going to be cut thr it's mean
not I'm going to value my time and make
sure I squeeze everything out of my days
to ensure we maximize and I'm I'm so
obsessed of just improving and I went to
a webinar I've never been to a webinar
before in terms of like big motivational
speakers one of the best guys there said
instead of Internet research reading all
of that stuff that takes time go
straight to the experts pay the experts
real life examples and situations of
what works question be coached by them
be mentored and get straight to it and
that's what I do I want to get straight
to the source of how to be a better
person and that's why I invest in myself
what what do you think as a CEO of a
pretty fast growing recruitment company
do you think has been has had the most
impact do you think cuz there's a quite
a few different things there right you
might go it probably might not be
business it could be public speaking or
a therapist like what do you think
they've obviously all affected you in
all different ways but what do you think
has really enabled you to perform at
high levels as a CEO out of those
different things you've invy really yeah
yeah it's changed my life like changed
my life I'm I'm calm I'm collected I
think about my thoughts I think about my
actions I think I'm happy like if I'm a
miserable CEO all the time then no one's
going to buy into that I want like I
said I want to walk into rooms
interviews included I want to inspire
people and I want people to walk away
and think I want to [__] work for him
that's what I want it sounds like you
just become a lot more self-aware yeah
for sure and it's not like I want to be
cocky or arrogant it's that I want to be
a better person like I'm obsessed with
being a better person right and i' I've
I've done a lot of things that I've
probably don't agree with with my past
and stuff like that and I I want to be
an inspiring person you know I want to
prove people that anything's
possible now if we get into some of the
like recruitment recruitment stuff right
what I really picked up on when I was
listening back to our last uh
conversation and you also mentioned this
at our live event as well so the
question I have here is like how
fundamental has it been to your growth
to sell Staffing products not fill jobs
you was like really passionate about
that when we sat down he was like that
you know you don't become Elite by
chasing jobs and asking if people got
jobs like we solve problems we have Sol
solutions for problems and I think
that's what's like really evident I
think whenever we've spoken is you do
think about things differently or
there's a lot of people speaking about
productization these things I know you
was quite early on on that but how
fundamental has that been to your growth
and I think just to give a bit more
context with people at a live event this
might have changed but you said you you
have five products to Market and this is
where you see you can take up even more
market share yeah from your client so
you put te uh teams as a service s s so
teams as a service to hire so contract
to perm Contract Services contract to oh
sorry that was wrong contract to hire is
more contract to perm and then retained
so there's five different Services there
let me know if any of those are wrong
and you can correct me but how how
fundamental has that been to your growth
cuz that is different to doing
contingent contract deals in ones and
twos right mhm we so we've I've I we
I've always trained a
team um up till since I've been leading
and uh coaching people and whatnot is is
that we're different we I say what I
said to said to my team what is the
difference you pitch in a 500 person
company to a 100,000 person company
nothing literally nothing okay it's
another person behind the phone it's a
human being right and as soon as you can
get over that hurdle and understand that
and that's why I train people someone
asked me other day what makes interet
different we P we train people i p pitch
properly it's not people don't buy what
we do everyone always tells what we do
contingent recruitment they B to how we
do it mhm and if we can demonstrate
impact and value for our service with
won people pay you money right and this
is the difference between us and how we
train people is consultative approach
productization offering a service and a
solution to a pain and a problem and how
we can demonstrate that how we can make
impact and value for our service and
that is sales to the next level right
and that that's the biggest thing for me
and I said to my whole team as a kickoff
this week we we talk a lot about
personal growth at interex and that
separates us right but I said are you
improving as a sales person
and if you improve as a Sal person like
learning Sal properly technically you
outbeat everyone and that's the same
with what we do is that we want to go
into products sorry projects and
programs and identify how we can support
in more of a global scale offering a
whole team as a
service and is that because of that
approach has that mean that has that
meant that your average contract value
is a lot higher has that enabled you to
have the cash flow and you know the
resources to reinvest because when you
do win a client or when you do win a
project it isn't one or two contractors
going out each week right is that is
that been quite fundamental we've got
some huge accounts like huge accounts
and like big Enterprise and we have some
people that join us be like wow You' got
some big clients here it's like yeah but
what pitch them then like that's all you
need to do you train people properly to
pitch and they pitch and that's the
biggest thing is I um and we'll come on
to our new training program that we've
got and it's amazing in terms of our
strategy to on board people to make them
absolutely great um but yeah for sure
like we have some big clients and I'm
grateful for that and it it helps with
our um quality of earnings all of that
having these big Brands behind us is
allowed us to do a lot of
things that that was my next point so
let's talk about the training because I
think whenever when we sat down last
time you was just as passionate about it
and I do I do really agree with you is
like when you talk about what makes it
different and I think we mentioned this
last time like how many recruiters out
there can effectively pitch their their
services it'd be interesting to know
obviously with the world that I'm in
training recruiters the sort of sales
element the BD element is often the
bigger skill Gap right so the fact that
you put so much energy and passion into
really equipping people with the skills
to pitch properly um is a huge
competitive Advantage so I think
something that really stuck out to me
and you've already mentioned it today
but what I really want for people
listening to understand and put an
underline under is when you talk about
people buy into how not the what and you
train people on the how would you mind
just telling us a bit about you know if
I'm joining interx and I'm someone who's
a contract recruiter I've done fairly
well and I see you talking about the
platform the training what are some of
the the things that I'm going to hear
listen experience it's going to make me
go [__] hell yeah like I can do an
extra 50% of what I was already doing
cuz I'm now thinking about this tell us
a bit about this training that you're
really passionate about yeah put
training to one side just for one minute
it first starts with how we motivate
people and the type of Skillet that we
bring in right like I said I don't
believe to be at the best level in
recruitment is just about pounding that
phone and working smart I believe the
best way in recruitment is mastering
your mindset okay and elevating
everything think about your life to be
the best recruiter so that's one thing
that we discuss a heck of a lot is how
we personally challenge people to grow
people personally it's a big thing for
me because otherwise you're not going to
be completely happy just to be
successful in recruitment does not
create just full happiness right how how
we challenge people to be better people
in general is a big thing for us that's
the first thing the second thing we have
an inter Excellence program right split
into four okay on different levels when
people come in right
our big belief is anyone that comes in I
say to everyone in my interview I don't
care what level you are I want you learn
in the interex way and that's what
separated us and always separated us you
look at you know Trevor Pinda right as a
big training platform we discussed
before he would tell you how I work
right and these are people that have
been involved in my business and they
run training programs and stuff like
that we're process driven we're strategy
driven we're mindset driven and we we
have a clear process that's repeatable
resilient and replicable and my chairman
discusses these fre RS all the time
right in terms of how we Scout our
business and that's what people look for
when they invest or they buy or whatever
is do you have a resilient repeatable
and rep replicable process we do and
we've created that this year or last
year sorry but that's because of the
infrastructure I've brought in I I've
you look at our infrastructure team
right we have one of the best
infrastructure teams in the industry I'm
confident about that um they they're
current they've been in big businesses
they've scouted business I've people
that Bas business is and they want to be
part of something ambitious now
something that's that's happening right
now what is what is the talk of of the
industry it's us and and it comes down
to everything that we're doing and any
our commitment is anyone that walks
through our door we will improve them
and I say it to everyone seniors incl
included and and that's a big thing for
me is knowing that we reinvest into
people we make people great and that's
why we have our TA strategies be part of
the 1% and we're seriously excited about
launching that yeah no do do I do like
why I do like the fact that you said
well before we go into all of the
recruitment specific interex way we
really need to make sure that we're
trying to encourage them to be the best
person they can be I think I heard you
say When I Was preparing for this like
by you really investing and being the
best person you can be outside of work
that then enes to be the best person in
work right and I definitely agree with
that when your mindset is right when
you've built really good quality habits
that just you know enable you to be the
best version of yourself that's going to
enable you to be the best version of
yourself in in work as well not just
only personally so I think that that's
great that you do that I want to talk to
you bit about having an interex way I
think this is so a lot of the companies
I speak to and the companies that we
support are in the stage where you was
at when we l sat down so like between 15
to 30 and my sort of insight I feel like
is whenever I speak to companies that
find themselves you know going to first
back to 20 whatever like really struggle
to get to the the scale that you have
yeah I actually think one of the core
reasons why is what you're talking about
having a repeatable the fre RS that you
just mentioned they don't have a process
on how they pitch how they win clients
these things so I don't know if this is
the case for all the your offices right
but I've I saw a picture of your
non-negotiables in the New York office
but I don't I don't know if this is true
for this so you have to tell me so
you're non-negotiables on the big banner
in the New York office are the following
on phones by 8:30 a.m. yeah Power hours
standing always follow the process Day
plans every day bull horn is the truth
outperform other offices uh come
prepared and leave with actions we pitch
um at DES 10 before 10 don't accept
under performance is that like your
non-negotiables across the group you
have office so what what one thing that
we did right is we're big about culture
and vision okay um I'm huge about it
like we're like infrastructure team are
huge like I've got Haley who's our HR
and people director um Amy um myself and
Lisa that were heavily involved in
transforming our culture and vision
right and um we wanted each office to
have their DNA like who are each office
Miami London and New York what the
non-negotiables and what the coach are
coach are sorry and we also done above
the line and below the line but we got
everyone to participate into what that
is in agreement with our New York office
is about hiring sorry experienced
recruits experienced team okay and that
was our goal for that and that was that
was the that was what they wanted to
Define collectively and it was why is
behind that how's behind that and
reasons behind that um we done above the
line and below the line and what the
offices each expect like what they think
is below the line that they don't want
to tolerate in the office and what is
above the line like we love that [__]
you know and that's for New York which
I'm saying for Miami and then all of
them together came into the overall
Global strategy and culture and vision
that we have
and that's what we wanted to do is to
create office Visions office cultures
office non-negotiables that all falls
into the whole Global strategy that we
have and it it it works it's
competitive okay it's setting the bar we
we want to be an elite team we don't
need to be a thousand people to sell for
a shitload of money right we need to be
an elite team of people that want to win
want to challenge themselves in life
okay and want to go to the next level
and that's who we are the platform that
we offer okay and I say to my team I
said to my team my kickoff today you can
work for a business that offer flexi
hours part-time 9 to5 all of that [__]
yeah and do 100K a year or 200k a year
or come work for us be challenged be
motivated Be Inspired be part of a
vision be part of a team and culture be
part of a business that can improve you
and income work for us and that's the
difference you can you can choose each
path we don't want people that want to
choose paf and there's recruiters out
there that probably might see and say oh
you know you can't drive a business like
this
people told me that 3 years ago yeah
there's so many people out there that
are winners like like goal mindset all
of that stuff I want people that are
hungry I want to give people an
opportunity within this business to show
that they have a platform to be
absolutely great and that's what we
offer and again we our our TA strategy
is be part of the 1% that doesn't mean
that we discriminate cuz I'll be honest
with you 90% of my team haven't gone to
University haven't gone to college
haven't had a great upbringing I love
that and and we want be part of 1%
because we know that there's the 1% out
there and we want to we want to show
people how you could be part of the 1%
in the recruitment industry yeah it's
about I totally get that in terms of you
want people that generally want big
things for themselves 100% And they want
to be challenged not everyone wants to
be
challenged um that's my biggest
fulfillment right is knowing that we can
make people change their lives like I've
seen so many people start with with a
certain work attire and they finish a
year on a certain work attire that just
shows the difference of of of
transformation they've been through
their happiness that they've been
through the promotion they've been
through the pay packet they've been
through like everything and watching
that transformation journey is something
my whole leadership team buy into we'll
get back to the episode in just one
minute but today I wanted to tell you
about our partners sourcewell the
industry-leading business development
and head hunting platform I'm a
sourcewell user myself and it's been an
absolute Game Changer when it comes to
crafting personalized Outreach it's not
only quick and easy but you can tap into
custom variables automate follow-ups and
use multiple channels like the phone
LinkedIn email and more to accelerate
results users report an average increase
of 56% in qualified response rates and
when you're using it it's easy to see
why AI powered tools like content coach
and wh GPT improve your chances of not
ending up in spam something that's
become increasingly challenging with
Google's recent deliverability changes
it also tracks all of your activity into
your CRM keeps your data clean and lets
you know who you need to reach out to
and when so you can spend more time on
what you're good at recruiting not admin
so if you're serious about being the
best at what you do join me and
thousands of recruiters who have chosen
sourcewell to revolutionize their
Outreach approach book a demo with
sourcewell and mention the recruitment
mental podcast to enjoy an extra 50
phone and 50 email credits per user and
this exclusive offer will save you Circa
£500 and more and it's only available
until March the 31st click the link in
the episode description or you can head
to source.com
slemo you speak you mentioned it quite a
bit of the live event as well and I
think it' be just good to hear how you
like break it down a bit in terms of you
describe your business as a platform and
you're really passionate about this
platform we're talking about in
different ways here but just just share
with us I don't if I'm honest I've had a
lot of these
conversations I don't think as many
people use that word as as you do and it
it makes sense to me why cuz what we're
talking about you can join the interex
platform and this is then where we can
we can take
you we're talking about the
non-negotiables challenging people uh
the things that you invest in but like
what what are the the pillars of this
platform the way that you see it cuz I
think that would be interesting for
people to understand how you think about
this platform cuz you always use that
word yeah um first it's
for us to say that we got a platform has
got to be proven right um you've
interviewed some of my team you know the
sort of numbers at some my like my my
company and known do big numbers I know
that right everyone I speak to the the
the the messages I get everyone knows my
company do big numbers that's individual
Consultants like our average Cena does
over 12 and a half 13k a week average
that's average I got people scaling up
to sometimes even 70k a week M like
that's record break break and Industry
stuff and so it first starts with proof
like we can actually do that and also
just on that it doesn't matter how old
you are some people I used to get
knocked back on my age and stuff like
that doesn't matter how old you are you
can you can do these numbers if you put
your mind to it the next thing is the
culture that we've created like my my HR
people director and Amy and Lisa and all
all of our infrastructure team have
worked seriously hard on defining who we
are this year building a platform that's
giving back building a that's supportive
that that that really really elevates
people like that's huge for me like
people engagement was number one topic
for last year is making it the best
people engagement platform possible
where people can be happy fulfilled and
want to come to work you know and that's
a big thing for me and so many and I
said to my all of my teams in each
office as a kickoff we went through the
non-negotiables their culture and I said
you need to feel this you need to
believe in it you need to be part of it
because this is what you said wasn't
what I said M but you need to be part of
that vision of what you want to do
because otherwise you're not going to
back to the office you're not going to
be happy and you're not going to want to
win we all need to work collaboratively
to make this happen as a team and that's
what we've done so well is bringing
people together as a team my my my
leadership team my phenomenal I believe
I believe we've created a super super
super good senior leadership team which
has helped us to to to to structure us
into the position that we're in today um
and we train people right just going
back to the training the platform it's
the it's the training and anyone that's
come through our training will know that
we train people properly how to do
Recruitment and that sounds weird like
properly how to do recruitment right but
um but yeah a lot of people don't that's
just the honest truth um you've
mentioned it a few times let let's
really make sure that we understand this
cuz I I do think this has been from
outside looking
in one of the the big growth areas in
terms of the the infrastructure that
you've built yeah because there's no way
you're going to get to the plans that
you have in terms of grow by another 150
sales staff uh globally in 2024 get to
this business exit this business event
in three and three and a half years
there's no way you're going to do that
um without unbelievable infrastructure
and unbelievable people um in great
seats so would you mind just talking to
us a bit
about how how you've gone about that and
how you thought about it what I'm asking
you is like what what you might have got
help with this but like what did you see
to be when we think about this
worldclass infrastructure what were some
of the types of seats you need to invest
in first was it an Ops person was it
train a training person like how did you
visualize this um infrastructure in the
Ops Team would you mind sharing that so
I I believe I I've made mistakes in
hiring I've made mistakes in growing i'
I've made mistakes in all areas of my
life right with the business and outside
of business but some of my mistakes I
kept on making was hiring people that
just I I wanted to believe that they
could step into the role right okay and
I'm too ambitious for that and I'd love
for that to happen I'm too fastpaced I'm
too ambitious I'm too hungry to wait for
someone okay as simple as that so my
strategy was then I want to hire the
best people and I want to go out there I
want to reinvest and just get the best
people so just to clarify sorry one of
the learnings was you were maybe finding
yourself invested in like potential they
might not have got a full track record
yeah yeah okay cool they they could up
to my expectation and it doesn't mean I
was just a harsh bastard it was just
more that I have a goal I have a vision
if you can't work at this pace yeah then
it doesn't work I've had that and um and
like this might work for other companies
but I know where I want to go you know
I'm 30 years old and I've achieved all
of this in my life and I know I want to
exit this business and I want to do it
younger and quicker than anyone I can't
do that with people that are balls and
change and like my my my chairman is
very good with this and he reminds me of
who I am and who we want to be and what
we want to do and where we want to go
and um I just said I want to get the
best people now I want to make sure I
get in front of people and I want to win
people over so I worked on me first
because I needed to make sure that
people could buy into what my story and
what I wanted to do cuz I you know when
as I was um as I was developing as a CEO
I had people you know feedback on
interviews and sometimes it's good
sometimes it's bad it's 50/50 I'm now
95% if I get in front of someone I've
won them over I'm confident about that
because I believe that people want to
work for someone like myself cuz I want
to go places I'm not a talker I want to
go and do things you know I'm obsessed
with doing things and I want to make
people great so I just went and got when
and got the right people um I hir the
right people i' you know I I brought
in um well my my finance my finance
leaders have never worked out yeah so
that's always been a problem for me but
I've gotten a big big challenge but I've
got a great FD now I've got um a great
uh contracts and compliance director dor
M HR and people director so I've got Rob
Stewart Haley MH um I've got Amy our Co
I've got lisos out EVP for growth okay
I've got Virginia who heads up out
marketing globally so I built a
phenomenal team like phenomenal team and
um these are all people that have been
there and done it yeah that are
collaborative they're still they're
still hungry people though right yeah
yeah is there just thinking for people
listening that are on this scaling
Journey just quickly um what would would
you say is really what would you invest
in first if I'm going on a scaling
Journey um in terms of like on the
infrastructure side is it an Ops person
is it Finance if you're a sales leader
bring in an Ops bring in a good Ops
person for sure sooner rather than later
and everything you can build everything
around of course you can focus more
right I'm not saying I I do Focus for
sure like Amy is a
Workhorse but she um I work well with
her and I'm um the the partnership is
great but I have a good partnership with
all of my senior I work with all of them
very close with Lisa cuz she she drives
our operations in the US so I work great
with all of them right and um I think
he's he's I'm unfortunate like I'm very
grateful unfortunate but do you know
what my advice is is stop being so tight
and put your hand in your pocket and
that's biggest everyone's biggest
problem I want one person to do three R
just like just just and I'm not afraid
of spending a bit of money right and
because I want to be the best like if
you're not going to take risks and
you're not going to take some step backs
to go 10 steps forward then you're not
entrepreneur an entrepreneur is take
risks scales a business wants to wants
to grow something wants to sell
something but and that's my biggest
thing is people CR comment on profit I
don't care about my [__] profit you
know I care about the the the the
success of this business and how how
this business is so great and we
invested so much money last year and I I
believe in it I back here and look at
the position we're in now so what I
really like about what you shared there
was
again like you doing the self work of
maybe realizing that maybe I could be
coming across a bit better in these
interviews or perform better in
interviews and that's going to be
absolutely crucial if I'm going to be
able to hire people like Amy for example
um in these seats so one of the one of
the points here I don't know what else
you want to add to this but I think as
you've gone on this
journey uh you've really had
to change the culture in the right way
with growth yeah so Diversified your
Workforce you know naturally it's it's
matured I think when we sat down I think
I remember you saying that age the
people in your business were like 18 to
26 yeah all standing on the tables
calling I mean our heads you've had to
you know as you've gone on this journey
and you continue yeah um you've had to
quite and quite mature right different
age groups New York offices mainly
experienced recruiters senior leadership
team there's a lot of female presence
these things so talk to us a bit about
that journey and how you've gone about
that obviously you spoken about the
infrastructure but how important has
that been for sure
um I I had a big thing for last year is
that I wanted we just want to be a
better business we want to be more
diverse um we want to look I'm not I
won't just hire someone just because of
their age and I'm not looking to do that
right but we have matured naturally
we've matured but we matured with right
people I'm not going to hire a 40 50
year old just because I need more age in
my business that's not for me at all but
we've got 50% of our our leadership are
female mhm like that's huge I think even
bit more than that we've got language
speakers now my my new director in
Europe is uh which was from Belgium
relocated Oliva we've now got a
sponsorship license for Europe where we
can bring on anyone across Europe into
the UK um our New York office was all
about experience highes you look at my
New York team is super strong um we've
done a lot we've done a heck of a lot my
mind Miami team is is a very much a
diverse office if you can say that but
it's a great team Miami culture and I'm
going to be biased cuz I run that office
so I did run that office it's such a
prime example of who you want to
be like Fast Pace collaborative people
from all walks of life come in and
everyone wants wants one goal has to be
successful I've had enough of people
saying UK is different to us yes it is
slightly but it's winners everywhere in
the world literally
literally everywhere and this is the
thing is that um we've had to adapt
we've had to evolve because of the
business we are today like if I didn't
have some of my leaders in senior
leadership now as females we probably
wouldn't have hire some of our people
right yeah we've got like female
directors everywhere from a S
perspective and nons and it's again like
I'm very fortunate to have these people
and these are winners these are people
that have an intention to be great
intention to sell attention to be
successful like we have a very very much
so unified leadership team of where we
want to go as a business and it's it's I
think it's rare let me ask you this then
what do you think people outside looking
into inters often get wrong when judging
what it might be like to work for your
business they get me wrong I think
because um I used to get a lot of
feedback so all of my senior leadership
team got told not to work for me by m
really yeah yeah that's interesting they
told you that all the yeah all the time
all the time I get people tell so before
they joined you
said not sure I'd work for Jamie lots of
people have said don't work for Jamie
okay I've had stories where people said
I used to Chu chairs at people I Chu
phones at people I never knew that so
maybe it might be someone's dream but I
don't know but everyone that does work
for me and I'm not being arrogant or
cocky will tell you how I am I'm caring
I give back I'm positive I back my team
to the absolute fullest it's my team
against everyone okay and I lead I lead
from the front right people I don't I
don't have people join me that quit okay
and I think that says a lot about me
people might have this perception about
me it's jealousy okay beat my trap
record I won two entrepreneur of the
years an entrepreneur of the Year Awards
last year okay no one's ever done that
Great Britain and the recruitment
industry okay I believe it's jealousy I
believe it's people can see that I'm
going places but if you look at my team
they'll tell you the type of leader I
really am um that's that matters that's
all I care about yeah now it's all I
care about because now it's about okay
you can criticize me but you can't
criticize when my business is going
exactly and that's the big difference
and that's why I said to you about the
self-aware the self-analyze the
self-discovery and stuff like that i'
done that cuz I wanted to be a better
person yeah and yeah I might have done
some shitty things in the past we will
have exactly we'll get back to the
episode in just one minute but today I'm
excited to talk to you about one of our
partners Firefish the recruitment CRM
that accelerates datadriven growth they
have just released their 2024
recruitment agency report based on
insights from over 200 agency leaders
the report offers unbelievable insights
into forecast for the year ahead
enabling you to refine your strategy
Based on data rather than intuition here
are some of the stats I personally found
interesting from the report although
industry optimism has declined for the
third year in a row growth signals
remain positive with 84% of agency
leaders expecting year-on-year sales
growth this year 47% of agency leaders
plan to use a contingency recruitment
model in 2024 and 70% of agencies plan
to use social sourcing as their main
candidate attraction strategy in 2024
you can access your free copy of the
report and start making datadriven
decisions about your business by
clicking the link in the show notes and
whilst you're there if you wanted to
check out how fir fish could help your
business grow this year they very kindly
offered a unique offer to our community
the recruit mentals podcast that's going
to save you up to £1,000 and this offer
is only available until March the 31st
you can click the link in the episode
description and you can also head to
Firefish software.com
slrm this brings you quite a nice point
on I read your post on turning 30 and
then you like wrote a bunch of a list of
things I think the perfect point I only
writee two down um which I really liked
uh first one some someone that talks
about you in been in front of you I
think that's quite on point for this and
I wanted to ask you cuz I think it's it
is evident you've been on this personal
growth uh Journey but I wanted to ask
you that in terms of where you think
people often um go wrong so I found that
interesting yeah I think that's a really
good manag to deliver by like someone
that if you put too much weight on what
other people telling about you m you
don't really gain anything from that but
remembering that you know these people
that do talk about you will never be in
front of you you're on your own Journey
my chairman said said that to me really
I love that I think I think that's Mega
some someone that we talk about you
never be in front of you I think that's
that's a great that's a great Insight um
tell tell us
about a lot of actually yeah maybe more
people talk about wanting to get to some
sort of exit um and very few people do
yeah so what I'd love to get your uh
take on is just to get a bit technical
here from what you understand and have
learned so far on this journey working
with people like um deel chairman like
to get to this business event what is
what is going to be the biggest
contributor to Enterprise Value like
what you know looking at your business
or when you think about your business in
three three and a half years time what
are going to be the most valuable parts
of it because it can't be Jamie driving
the business so like you know is it tell
us a bit about that cuz I think that'll
be some good insights for people so my
obviously my Chairman's been brought in
for various reasons his experience I
work with him I work closely with him or
work with him and he doesn't work with
lots of companies which is something I'm
grateful for Because he believes in what
we want to do M um he talks about
quality of earings a lot and this this
is a guy that sold multiple businesses
he's bought and sold and bought again
you know so I want it to bring him in
because I want experience so first of
all is bringing in good chairman I think
it's the first thing second thing is the
quality of earnings right so that means
big relationships which we've got so
like with like clients like Enterprise
clients and stuff we're 90% contract now
yeah so you've always been very contract
heavy so there's recurring Revenue there
we're building a brand called Enigma
which is all about pure s so and we've
got people at latter stages of interview
and we're going to really Elevate that
this year um and why does that help the
value is it because the types of bus
people um when you go for yeah okay s so
the multiplier goes straight through the
roof and it's something I'm super
excited I'm passionate about why why
does it go up is it because the contract
values are much higher is it because
yes consultancy contract values is
everything to do with that like having
that as an add-on to to the business
shows that you're offering more than
just it's a service at the end of the
day um repeatable resilient replicable
processes like a template yeah so if we
can show to someone who buys us that
this box of interex of who we are the
process where working if we open up
Austin which is our next office that
we're going to open if it opens it goes
like that and it's successful repeatable
exactly and that they're they're the
biggest things that we're looking at
right now and how just der risking the
business a little bit but we're on the
trajectory to do all of this like if you
look at everything I've said now
everything's in process like we our eyes
are on the goal now you know we've just
created a 20 like we don't have a 2024
plan now our plan is 2024 to 2026 that's
our plan and we have our eyes on exactly
what we need to do now and it's tunnel
vision to make it happen and how do you
fit in because I think sometimes from
you know I have friends who are in
senior positions and businesses that
talk about we're going to sell one day
and these things but what I hear time
and time again is it can be difficult
for these people to be less Hands-On you
said how much you're involved because
you enjoy it and how you're passionate
about it but from what I understand if
me and you have a meeting and I'm
talking to you about potentially buying
interx or you know buying you out for
example I'm not going to be excited if I
find that if we take Jamie out a lot of
this drive and performance isn't going
to be there so if you get if you achieve
all those things what does your role
look like towards the end of that cuz I
think that would be interesting for
people to understand is it that you're
less and less hands on like how do you
fit into that yeah we obviously we've
naturally got to pull me away from a lot
of these things the goal by the end of
2024 is and I said to all my leadership
you make me redundant in your success
how do you feel about
that
great but sometimes people cuz like
that's we'll go on to like the other
things that you have maybe this helps
but if you didn't have anything else
going on on other in initiatives you're
really passionate about that's your
purpose potentially taken away of course
but and I say it before success does not
determine by the money you earn it
determines by the impact you make on
people and my goal this year is to
impact people big time and um I want to
delegate properly we've got a strategy
to do that don't get me wrong I thought
hard about this right and I think that
when I opened up New York I emailed um
Amy and I said oh do I need to be here
really because feel like I'm I'm a
little bit bored because it's like the
first week I was like I don't feel like
because Amy Amy and Lisa dealt with it
right CRA on I got it all done I was
like oh so it's it's working it's it's a
changing my mindset right but don't get
wrong I I don't want to work parttime
right I always want to be involved in
the business I think my biggest thing is
can I focus on other things that can
Elevate this business ideas strategy
like I'm always in the business oh
different brands for example yeah I'm
always in the business I need to be more
on top of the business and this year is
about being on top and I said to all my
senior leaders this year I said you make
me redundant in your
success I love that and that's so
important for people to hear because if
you're in a recruitment business right
now and they've dangled the carrot in
front of you saying we we're going to
exit but still they try and just have
their hands on
everything it's going to be very
difficult to sell that that business
right so if I if you're telling me
you're like you know you need to make me
redundant in your success like that's
what you want to hear if the big goal is
I'm gonna be part of this journey I'm
gonna hopefully get shares in this
business by performing and doing what I
need to do and I'm going to be rewarded
for that when you know however it works
jamy being bought out or whever however
it works right in terms of who's going
to be at the table but if you're not
hearing that in the business where
they're dangling that carrot in front of
you that that's a red flag for me and I
always say that to people cuz you know
it sounds great to say like yeah Jamie
we're going to give you shares in our
business but that means [__] all unless
anything happens right but people know
that I mean business you know I'm
serious about everything everything I
don't [__] no one and you know I'm
very black and white and some people
love it some people don't I don't care
like you get what you see with me and if
I say something's going to happen it's
going to happen so tell us about it's
been interesting to see this outside
looking in so we've mentioned Enigma
which you're excited about in terms of
going to continue to elevate the
Enterprise value of interex as a whole
how does jfg fit into all of this then
yeah so I as I said I have a passion for
impacting people I've gone through a
transformation Journey in my head that's
and I say like when I speak at events
and podcasts I shouldn't be in the
position I'm in today on paper
everything that's happened in my life I
shouldn't be where I am today but I I
have and I've done it through working
right people my mindset and stuff like
that so I'm creating a coaching and and
and training platform to take people
that come from adversity and all of that
stuff to train them how to get a mindset
right whether it be consistency habits
routines goals whatever that looks like
big process around the mindset to then
sell to anyone but then to Brand to
anyone people are forgetting branding
branding is the biggest thing for any
successful business and it's something
that I'm going to be driving hugely this
year with my brand personally and with
interex so I'm creating a platform
effectively like I don't think there's a
good enough platform youve got Grant
code own for sales out there you got
these but there there is a new
generation coming through now for sure
and I'm going to make that happen and
that's my goal is to have the number one
transformation Journey globally I love
that yeah um and how's it going so far
uh first 8 weeks um I tested the water
it didn't go to my plan I wanted I've
evaluated I've looked I've evaluated
even further and the lot in December s
just been going up and up and up and up
and up and I haven't even started I me
you just really like the idea of just
helping B your young your younger self I
want to change lives and I have people
approach me all over the world uh
contact me on Instagram I got a very big
foll me on Instagram got a lot of people
that speak to me follow me and the
difference between myself and a lot of
these other coaches out there I'm proven
I've been known and done done it young
cuz that is the thing online isn't it
I'm sure when you've done your research
yeah yeah it's easy you've really got to
check where you're getting your
information advice from 100% And I think
really you want to gravitate towards
it's like why you've invested in your
chairman and the people like they've got
a track record and it's very easy to
share things online and take him from
things from people that haven't got that
track record
100% um so paint a picture for us then
we sat down three years ago yeah you're
here now we've spoken a bit about you
know getting driving towards this
business event you've got some big
growth plans this year right so I've
said looking to high 150 sales staff
you've mentioned Austin like I'd
really if we would sat down another
three years what conversation are we
having yeah what are things going to
look like I've got offers on the table
that we're looking at that we're
evaluating that we're digesting like I'm
happy my team are happy my team are
motivated my team are eager to get this
done you'd see a business that we we've
like we've got one of the best brands on
LinkedIn best growth on LinkedIn like we
just I want interet to be the best brand
I believe last year we really stood out
from a lot of our competition and in the
recruitment industry and we're not even
the biggest in the next three years I
want to be the best recruitment company
to ever be sold that's my goal and one
of my biggest things is someone said to
me other day we so we're looking to
acquire businesses right yeah I saw that
so if like anyone watching that wants to
be acquired wants to be part of our
group and processes and stuff like that
and want to what's the idea behind that
is that obviously very strategic
strategic in terms of the fact of we
want to grow faster we believe we've got
the right structure to take on a
business and we we've got three
companies we're speaking to and these
three companies are 20 to 50 person
companies and our proposition to them is
that you will sell for more through us
under the under the entire group because
price value will increase my
infrastructure team is ready for a lot
of people and that's the big thing so
we're ready to take on companies but um
I I went I was speaking to a business
owner and he said oh you know I went to
get investment um and they said oh you
know you own 100% I'd recommend you give
shares out to the business and I said
wait a minute I said I give shares out
to a lot of people and my Christmas
party I said S3 made all of these
millionaires I want to do the same I
want to make multiple millionaires in
this business this business is not just
about me and earning a shitload of money
I know I earn money in my life but I
want I'm big about impact on people and
change people's lives and people know
working for me they'll get a piece of
the pie and I don't dangle carrots so Ju
Just One on two things firstly just on
that I think be curious to know how how
do you incentivize becoming a
shareholder like how does that work is
it done on performance like I'm sure it'
be different ways but typically if I
join your business how could I become a
shareholder how have you thought about
that yeah client it starts at client
manager so one of above a principle you
go to client manager or you go from a
manager up anything manager upwards
basically BD and gives you the right to
get access shares you start and it it
goes it phases up to see sweet nice yeah
so everyone gets a piece quite quite
early on in their career sure and is it
is it done then on is it done on
performance or is it just done obviously
if you're getting to that point you're
progressing and you're performing hit
that you you you a promotion we made
four more people share hers this year
that's I'm right Christmas yeah it's
amazing like they're over the moon like
I've I've got people that are have been
with me for a long time and the time was
right to start giving the shares back to
these people and like that I'm not a
selfish person like it was it pissed me
off and this guy was like oh you should
go and do this no you've done that wrong
we're we're doing that you know I'm big
about that I'm not I'm I said like if
you speak to my senior leaders and my
people that work directly I care I give
back can I give a [__] yeah and I
guarantee you as well uh obviously
you're not doing it just for this reason
but like when you get to that
moment are you going to remember the
millionaires that you made and the
impact that you made or you going to
remember what you felt like when you saw
the money in your bank account I'm
pretty sure it's going to be that's
impact on people that's what you
remember the most true success is impact
on people it doesn't matter how much you
earn that's not successful successful is
the impact that you replicate to other
people great that you've made it I'm
assuming that's like super Vis visible
and easy to understand and I think
that's the most important thing with
stuff like that is it's just completely
transparent if you get here this family
shares you get if you get here this
family shares you get so that's great
you've made that really clear and like
one of the other things that we're going
to start doing is doing a shareholders
meet in every quarter to discuss the
strategy and just also influence exactly
we want everyone to be part of the
vision that we go through and this
culture it's vision and that's why the
people we have involved that all
thinking the same way you know and that
it's it's huge for me and that's what
separates us we've got a great culture
we collaborate we incentivize and we
drive the business in the right
way the other thing I just wanted to
make sure I ask you because it'd be
interesting to get your take CU how long
have you been open to the idea of
acquiring and rolling in great companies
under interest group has that been over
the last 12 months Q4 Q4 so fairly
recent yeah what
um my question is like what is it that
you really look for that makes you feel
like this company has
potential because again I think people's
perception of that could be different
like I'm sure you've met people that
that go into the conversation going my
business is Jamie should be very
interested in my business and you speak
to him like yeah not not sure this is
actually up to Mark so what what are
like the core things that you are always
trying to identify and look for when you
started to have these conversations
they've got good relationships and
they're not just 180 doing delivery they
actually BD P out the phone and they
want to be better um to be honest with
you there's some companies out there
they just complete 180 model and it's
just like couldn't be anything worse in
the sense that they have some big house
accounts and they just deliver that's it
and that's why they're not grow in
that's why not developing because they
don't have BD people it's difference we
are we're BD through and through right
we train people to be BD machines and
like that that's what's got us through
hard times Co included and last year you
know last year was a tough year for
everyone including us um and our BD
techniques and strategies obviously
elevated by 5 10 15% right um but we're
looking for people that have got
relationships BD entrepreneurial mindset
and we want people that that want to be
part of something special like have the
sort of same ambition as us but just I
think we want to take over people that
don't have the infrastructure that don't
have the vision the direction that's a
huge value ad that you can give them
massive massive and often times if
they're at the sort of type of size that
yeah speaking to I've been there and
done it is [__] hard and that would
be a big pain for them yeah for sure
it's so hard to go from 50 to 100 people
is the hardest I I haven't seen going
from 100 to 200 yet but going to 50 to
100 wow cuz culture you got to think of
everything like it's crazy yeah one bad
problem affects multiple people and the
list goes on it's it's hard yeah that's
exciting then that maybe there might be
one or two brands that are part of this
journey then with you yeah excite you as
well very very it's it's and I I'm proud
about that I want to be top Co always
want to be top company like I don't ever
sell to a recruitment group cuz it's you
don't leave a
leave a legacy right and big for me um
it's big for my team as well my team
want to sell
interx is that that's interesting you
think that cuz there's been the the you
know from like recent um Acquisitions
it's been like bigger like investigo for
example I know that um actually quite
well investigo acquiring bio Talent
that's like a bigger recruitment group
buying you don't like the idea of that
no no no way no way who do you visualize
I'm sure you you have to think about
this right what what sort of um tables
you want to be at that would in terms of
that would fit the type of um vehicle to
buy INX is it more of a PE Farm is it
100% PE I think like I've had I've had a
couple offers already right um last year
I had an offer and a year before that I
had an offer and um these are from big p
back companies one's an American based
company but it's not it's not enough
like I need to be fulfilled if I sell
now for 50 million it's not enough not
enough for my myself or my team my team
pissed off as well do you would it be
again might might or might not be
something that you've thought about but
do you see it being like you would be
completely they would just buy the
entire company and I don't know that's
um every day I'm learning yeah so I've
never I've never had a company this size
i' never dealt with money this size
anything this size can you move closer
to again yeah I've never dealt with
anything this size so every everything
I'm doing is learning now and this is
the thing if I'm learning I don't know
what 3 years is going to look
like it's exciting though yeah for sure
for sure what um just final note like
what you take growth really seriously
personally what are some of the things
that you'd really like to continue
growing in over the next couple years so
when we next sit down sit down what what
are some of the things personally you'd
really like to yeah grow in become even
better at yeah so I want to be the
number one motivational speaker in the
UK and the next yeah yeah big about that
so I've got public speaking clach right
um and for someone that had a stutter to
now now I would just want to show people
that anything's possible so I want to be
the number one public speaking coach in
the UK but I want to conquer the US
market it's big thing for me um I want
to I want to just be more I want to be
more and more more clear about me as a
person my mindset how to master it I
believe that I've kind of Master my
mindset and I'm bit of a freak when it
comes down to like what I want how I
want it and my work ethic and all of
that but I want I want to elevate like I
said I I believe I'm here for more than
just work eat sleep work eat sleep I'm
here for more than now I want to impact
people right so how I can Elevate that
more isn't just about recruitment
anymore for me it's
about the The Wider impact that I can
make across the community and World in
general and that's that's the sort of
stuff that gives me a thrill excites me
gets me out of bed yeah for sure like
for sure and that's why I've got this
new business because I know can make so
much impact on people and like all these
other old Sal trainers and and stuff
like that people that are so big stuff I
know I can do it better than them and
that's that's my mindset and I've got a
great team around me to allow us to do
that I think it's super important for
young men today to have more run
modelers right and access to people that
can help them fulfill their potential
and help them feel like they can do more
yeah right yeah yeah um I'm female I'm
female yeah absolutely um Jamie look
it's been an absolute pleasure to see
your um honestly outside looking in I've
L loved seeing your growth um I just
really respect you making the real
investment in yourself um I think that
says a lot um about you and um what
you're about and yeah have no doubt at
all we'll be sitting down another three
years time and be you know at the
appropriate time be talking about the
tale of of selling interest is
going thanks for having me I appreciate
it